OK, in this section, let's take a look at the last pillar of the collaboration production
pipeline and see what additional collaboration tools are being implemented for our project
workflows.
So we already know that the Epic Games version control solution utilizes Perforce.
From there, Epic Games asset tracking is managed through ShotGrid.
But what is our third collaborative production pillar?
Well, Epic Games teams use a mix of video conference tools, for example, Zoom, along with asset
review tools like SyncSketch, alongside other internal asset review tools for interactive
collaboration during a production.
So what is SyncSketch?
Well, SyncSketch is a visual communication tool that allows remote teams to review
and annotate media in real time.
SyncSketch also offers integrations with a variety of other DCC applications, such as
Autodesk Maya and ShotGrid, along with generic Python API access for media import automation.
Epic Games utilizes this integration with ShotGrid specifically to access ShotGrid playlists
and synchronized notes and sketches on the backend.
Alright, that finishes our collaboration production pipeline.
In our next section, let's begin wrapping up this course with some final recommendations.